[Music]
I'm Sid. I'm one of the co-founders of
Aliv and this is the new lean startup.
We've been seeing a fundamental shift in
how successful companies are being
built. More and more companies are
getting smaller, rounds are getting
delayed, and profitability is being
attained earlier than ever in their
lifetime. A lot of this is being driven
mainly by the advent of AI tooling.
These companies are generating millions
of ARR with teams smaller than most
startups engineering departments. The
age of bloated teams and endless hiring
rounds is over. Welcome to the era of
tiny teams.
First, a bit of background on Oliv.
We're building a family of iconic
consumer software products that we hope
will enable people to live better, more
fulfilling, and productive lives. We are
a tiny team that scaled to a scaled a
portfolio of virally successful products
to $6 million in R profitably and have
generated over half a billion views
across social media, achieving this with
a tiny team of just four. We're based
out of New York City. And here's a brief
history on us.
On the 26th of January in 2023, we
launched a Quizard AI mobile app. We
launched it with a Tik Tok video that
went viral overnight and generated
million views that turned into 10,000
users in less than 30 hours. We actually
started scaling with no LLM costs. This
is because back then we had the initial
codeex model launch which was in beta
preview. Funny enough, we were cycling
between 10 different accounts from our
friends um just so that we could uh
prompt engineer or generate these AI
outputs. Interestingly enough, Codeex,
even though it was meant for a as a
coding model, could be prompt engineered
for any open domain conversation. As you
all may know, it ended up being sunset
for abuse. We ended up getting a lot, we
end up getting reached out directly by
OpenAI on a few of our different
accounts that we were cycling through as
being one of the top model users um for
the Codex model at the time.
My co-founders and I then graduated and
then we moved to New York City um the
fall of 2023 where we started our back
to school campaign which was a series of
um man on the street videos across
different uh prestigious colleges in the
US. This is when we hit our first
million dollars in ARR and also achieved
profitability within the first nine
months of operating.
We then even had another successful
campaign in the spring of 2024 that got
us all the way to number six in the
charts of education alongside giants
like Dualingo, Photomath and Golf.
We then took all our learnings in the
spring of 24 and double down on a new
product, Unstuck AI, a study companion
tool for students. We were able to get
to a million users in under nine weeks
and generate over quarter billion views
across socials in a month.
A few weeks ago, we were able to get
both products in the top 10 in the
education charts. Unstuck went all the
way up to number three in the education
charts, right under Goth and Dualingo.
We've now also launched in stealth, our
third product, which is our first
product outside the education domain. It
took 3 weeks to build thanks to all the
blueprints that we've built in advance.
We'll speak more on this later. And I've
already reached a,000 plus users. By the
way, it's already profitable.
Our lean playbook boils down to three
key pillars. Operating principles that
lay the foundation of leanness, organ
organizational structure that set up the
systems for this leanness and AI tooling
augmentation which optimizes scaling.
Let me start with operating principles
which I believe is the main bedrock for
why we're so lean. It starts with
hiring. We either hire right or not at
all. We only hire 10xer generalists that
have multiple complimentary spikes in uh
similar fields. So for example, our
product engineers are full stack
developers, great product thinkers and
really good at fundamentals of computer
network for example. We also have
marketers who can code. We have
designers who can build and uh the
likes. We try to aim for people whose
complimentary spikes can shape and drive
10x outputs within the team. The second
key principle is profit first mentality.
We are relentless about prioritizing
profits because profit is power and
profit is focus. Profit gives us a clear
mechanism to make all our decisions and
guide a northstar for the company. This
leads to our third principle. Does this
move your KPI? Everyone in the company
owns a KPI. KPI alignment removes
micromanagement because
everyone is focused on moving their
metric week over week. This also means
decisions must be validated against this
KPI.
Our fourth principle is continuous
process refinement. For any repeating
process, we always ask how would we do
this better? Is there any way we can
improve? What was wrong about this run
that we this previous run? We view
failures in the company and issues in
the company as systems failures, which
lets us set up a feedback loop for
improving ourselves, improving the
process that we used both on an
operational standpoint, but also a
technical standpoint.
The fifth pillar is super tools. We're
pretty lazy. So, we like to consolidate
a lot of our workflows onto one platform
if we can. And that ends up being
meaning that we have to reinvent the
ways we use old tools. More on this in a
bit.
And the last principle I'd emphasize is
don't learn it twice. We believe in
building compounding benefits by
investing in technical playbooks and
operational blueprints. This allows us
to compound our benefits or compound our
learnings so that the benefits can be
yielded across new products. This is
exactly how we were able to hit a
million users on unstuck within nine
weeks taking everything we learned over
a year and a half on Quizard.
More on the super tools concept. For
example, one of our super tools is
Launch Darkly. The intended use case of
Launch Darkly is a feature management
platform that helps software teams
control and release features safely and
quickly. Here are some of our extended
use cases. We use Launch Darkly as a
manual traffic load balancer.
Specifically, we we put Launch Sharkly
in between all our LM calls so that we
can reroute traffic to different LM
providers based on hitting rate limits,
different strategic initiatives or
whatever. It just gives us an on-
the-fly mechanism for choosing where our
traffic goes and allows us to split
things within rate limits. This was
especially important in the early days
when rate limits were really tight and
also um it was hard to yeah rate limits
were really tight. It was hard to get um
quotas increased on individual
endpoints. Specifically, I'm talking
about Azure OpenAI.
The second extended use case is on
the-fly infrastructure changes. For us,
this looks like how on Unstuck, which
takes in a lot of files to ingest, for
specific file formats, we have a lot of
waterfall ingestion processes. What I
mean by that is we depend on a lot of
thirdparty services that can be
reliable. By using Launch Darkly, we're
able to change the prioritization of
these processes on the fly. So that if
one of these third party thirdarty
services goes down, we're able to
reorganize the service on the fly to
make sure it's up and running and
available to our users worldwide.
The third extended use case is UI
modifications and pay paywall
experiments without having code pushes.
We've built an experimentation layer
around Launch Darkly which allows us to
run and spin up experiments without
needing to make a code push.
The third or sorry the second pillar
that guides our leanness is our
organizational structure especially in
our organ especially in our engineering
org in the way we hire and that we
organize our engineers. For this we look
to Palunteer who successfully scaled
across multiple market segments. We
believe that we're building the consumer
version of Palunteer with our harvester
and cultivator model. Let me explain
this for harvesters. These are product
engineers similar to the pounder deltas
of the four deployed software engineers
that own and live and die by their
products. They're living in the metrics
working on AB experiments, building
features end to end, working with the
marketing team and effectively owning
the entire products existence.
Harvesters are people who build products
that people actually want and pay for.
Then we have the cultivators.
Cultivators are AI software engineers
whose main goal is building the
company's agentic operating system.
They're pioneering automation across
different business units including
marketing, design, product with the idea
of expanding infrastructure that affects
all the users everywhere and helps us
win in every market. Cultivators are
creating the foundation that let us ship
and scale faster in any market.
And finally, the last pillar is AIdriven
and AI and tool augmentation.
One important note in thinking about
this is when we think about hiring, we
like to think of tool use as being
something that will allow a 10xer become
a 100xer as opposed to the contrast
which is using tools to fill gaps and
augment the shortcomings of someone
who's not at the standard that we like
to hire for.
With that being said, we use a slew of
products for our day-to-day task
automation for things like script
writing, campaign analysis, operations,
code generation, and communications.
effectively by paying for a bunch of
services. We have augmented and enabled
everyone to have their own chief of
staff within the company.
Now, back to the blueprints. One more
thing is we believe heavily in
compounding benefits and reinvesting in
blueprints. This includes things like
code complete templates which build in
all the learnings that we've learned
over the two and a half years of scaling
products with virality in mind. reusable
internal libraries and modules that
govern our core um services that we use
like our LM providers and shared
infrastructure that we use across
applications such as our notification
system or the experimentation layer that
I talked about earlier being in consumer
experimentation is kind of the backbone
of everything we do and that's why it is
always built out as a first layer into
every new product that we launch
but while blueprints give us a
deterministic leverage and compounding
effects what happens when these
blueprints can be executed on demand by
systems that can learn and adapt and
coordinate faster than real teams. At Al
leave, we're thinking about taking this
further and how AI can augment the
future of our work. And this is devised
into well three specific stages. The
first stage is humanled tooling. We
build specialized tooling that sits and
is embedded into the workflows of our
different teams across marketing,
product, and design. This includes
things like internal dashboards,
scraping tools, and prompt chain agents.
The whole idea is we are trying to
augment the day-to-day task of anyone on
our team. Stage two of this automation
includes workflow automation where we
actually take off entire processes from
people in the team. I.e. we have now
consolidated on the individual tools
that we built them to augment their
workflows to now take over the entire
workflows. This fus frees up bandwidth
on their end to take on more interesting
task or or take take on more high
leverage opportunities within the
company.
The third stage of all this is
consolidating all the workflows that
we've built under one autonomous
decision-making system, i.e. an
orchestration of multiple agents working
together to serve the role of an of one
new employee. Part of the goal with Oliv
is to build a company where we hire
people for their strategic insight,
their talent, and their taste, but run
the entire company on a bunch of agents.
We've already started this to for
example, we've started building
platforms that drive our market research
so that we can find out lucrative
markets to launch our new product into
as well as our acquisition process as we
start to acquire new apps and scale the
company. This includes things like
agents that are scanning the markets
consistently and daily for lucrative
opportunities, um, categories are doing
super well, and trends in the market, as
well as scoring acquisition targets for
strategic fit.
We've also started scaling our and
augmenting our growth systems. The same
principles apply in terms of leveraging
tools and AI. We are trying to automate
our virality engine. This includes mon
monitoring content, having on the-fly
feedback loops be kicked off when we
have certain events being triggered and
also dealing with relationships as we
work with creators and influencers and
such.
But we think we can take this further.
We imagine a world where we can have one
strategic person sit on top of an army
of specialized agents. Instead of
managing people, it becomes a it becomes
a game of commanding capability. They
set the objective, the agents execute,
and the system improves over time. But
what we really want to build is a larger
future where we can have not just one
person running a team, but one person
running an entire product or commanding
a commanding multiple clusters of agents
that serve different business units. We
see a world where we can have people run
entire portfolios of apps themselves
just by leveraging the systems that we
build and automate over time. This is
effectively our vision. We're building a
portfolio of one person billion dollar
companies. As a quick aside before I
wrap up here, I will be talking tomorrow
about trellis which is which stands for
targeted refinement of emerging LM
intelligence through structured
segmentation. It is a framework that I
came up with for scaling reliable a AI
user experiences to 5 million users
designed specifically around our
virality engine i.e. it is built for
systems where you intend to go viral as
your main go to market. This will be
part of the testing the untestable talk
tomorrow at 2:20 p.m. in the s room.
Thank you for listening.
[Applause]
[Music]